- On this episode we talk
about competing with Elon Musk
Hulu subscriptions, and 22 year old Gary!
- [Voiceover] That was 22 with Gary.
- Yes.
(energetic music)
- You ask questions!
And I answer them!
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hello everybody, and welcome
to the #AskGaryVee Show.
I am Gary, Jesus Christ,
I really haven't done this in a long time.
Yeah, I mean listen.
Even the best of us get rusty.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 152
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Was that me mixing Wine
Library TV's intro?
Jesus Christ.
Hey, feeling good?
Fired up for this show clearly.
And really excited.
Haven't talked to you guys
in a little bit of time
and I apologize, been traveling, hustling.
Making things happen.
The Jets won.
I am now five for five on my predictions.
Do you bet?
Like it's time that people
start really betting.
I think the Patriots prediction
this Friday's show is going to be real.
What's today, Wednesday?
- [India] Wednesday.
- Good, and we're doing a show tomorrow?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- And Friday. All right,
we're going to roll.
India?
I think it's time to get into the show!
Oh!
Love it.
Let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Mario
asks "Suppose Elon Musk
"just started his own
media wine resale company
"competing with you in your neighborhood.
"How do you respond?"
- I would actually be,
like I would be fired up happy.
Because that is my game, not Elon's.
And so I,
and this is the straight up truth.
It is insane how I when
I hear that question,
how obvious this is to me that I would
absolutely destroy him and
he would fail miserably
if he was trying to beat me in that game.
In the same way that I would fail
if I decided to, you
know, invent rocket ships
into space and tesla cars
and things of that nature.
When I play my game, whatever that is,
building an agency,
building a wine retailer,
whatever I do next.
If I'm operating, right?
Forget about investing where it's
a little bit of a crapshoot.
Forget about JVs where I have partners.
Me, me, Gary.
If I'm operating, there's
not a single person
in the world that I'm
scared of at all ever
because the only thing that can happen
is both of us getting ours.
There is nobody that is going to beat me.
The markets are too big.
I'm going to get mines.
And so, I'm not scare of Elon, or Shmelon,
or Zucks, or Cubes, or Ashton,
or anybody about anything
that comes to do with
the game that I'm playing
because I'm going to win.
I'm going to win.
Could they possibly do
more business than me?
Sure, I mean I'm not excited about that,
but sure I guess it could happen.
I don't think there's another
agency over the last 4 years
that has grown at the size that we have,
and in the liquor business
the same thing happened.
But of course, somebody could
come along with that kind of talent.
But that's not going to
stop me from getting mine,
and so the answer to your
question is I would be pumped
because I think there
would be a lot of people
talking about why didn't Elon use his mind
and go and do start small businesses.
And two, I would enjoy the
victory that I would get
that would get me more screen cred
for punching Elon in the mouth.
- [Voiceover] James asks "Why
not go halves on the Jets
"or quarters and elevate the team
"to the level only Gary could.
"The owner has to see some
value in your methods.
"Seems like this might be something
"more realistic and attained sooner.
"Is it all or nothing?"
- James, it's all or nothing mainly
because the owner's not interested.
I mean, Woody Johnson is a billionaire.
He's doing his thing.
He's not outwardly reaching out to me.
He's rolling in going about his merry way.
And that's that.
And he's in control of that situation.
I'm not worried about it.
I'm focusing on what I can control,
which is amass enough wealth and power
and opportunity and narrative
and leverage and branding
to give me the best shot
to actually pull this off.
And so that's why.
Plus I would never go in for an ask.
Right, I would never be like
"Hello Mr. Johnson, why don't you
"sell me 25% of the company"
or things of that nature.
Just not in me.
I'm going to take it if I deserve it.
I'll get it if I'm good enough.
And so I'm focusing
every piece of my energy
doing things to put me in that position
because the amount of luck and serendipity
that has to happen for me
to even get that at bat,
literally the passing of the company on,
whatever Woody decides to do with it,
hopefully, hopefully he
owns it his whole life
and hopefully he lives
for a very long time
and hopefully because I'm much younger
I'm there in a position
to make that purchase
if his family doesn't
want to hold onto it.
So there's just a million
different variables
that come into play that
have to fall into place
but I just need to focus
on what I can control
and really for everybody,
that's the biggest thing.
Way too many of you, and I've been really
digging into my community in
the last three or four days.
A lot of, this has actually
turned into a really good question.
A lot of you just worrying
about shit you can't control.
Like, it's unbelievable.
I don't know what's the matter with you.
Like you can't control it, the end.
Like it's not super complicated.
You can't control the weather.
You can't.
Like, people literally
crying that it rained
during their like flea market or food fair
or I don't remember exactly what it was.
Like, okay.
But like, like, and then
like, then I was like
okay maybe it was just a single rant.
But like seven tweets, I'm like wha.
Like it rained.
Like Mother Nature (censored) you.
Take it like a woman.
And like, you know, and so, you know.
I just don't believe in crying
over things you can not control.
And so I just think about
the things I can control
and so please try to take this answer
and understand how important it is
to not dwell but instead reverse it
and think about what you can
be doing during that time.
You know if it rained, when it rained
during times I've done flea markets,
I packed up and went dollar
store and Toys R Us shopping.
You know, I didn't just
sit there and take my rain.
- [India] Was good.
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Yannick
asks "What's your opinion
"on always wanting more in life?
"Good, bad, and why?"
- That's a really good question.
My point of view on this is both.
Always wanting more in life seriously
while being very very content
and happy at the same time.
That's what I am.
You know, this is
something you may not know.
Though I would be disappointed,
and my ego, boy my ego
which is a nice part of me,
would really take a hit,
if a little weird genie
showed up right now, weird genie, got it?
Boom!
If the weird genie said to me,
"Hey Gary, I'm the weird
genie of the future.
"Bad news, you're not
going to grow anymore!
"This is it, you've plateaued!"
I'd be like, oh!
Like a big shot.
But I'd be like, all right.
Like, to me, like, I've
had a great run already.
Like, I've done really well.
And many people would be really happy
to have these professional
accolades and successes
as their entire life's work.
That would rip my heart
out of my body right now
if that were to be true.
You don't have to animate
them ripping my heart out.
No Mortal Kombat shit here.
But it is probably
surprising to some of you
because I don't talk about it as much
how content I actually am.
And so my point of view on
it is a very strong balance
of happiness and content
with what you've got
while being very hungry
and striving for real real victories
and upside and the climb and the game.
And so that's where I'm at.
And as you can imagine,
as you're probably listening to this,
that makes me very happy.
Like, it's probably a big
reason I'm so damn happy.
It's a nice place to be.
You like that?
- [India] Yeah.
- Thanks India.
I'm ripping it with you today.
- [India] Yeah.
- Yeah.
Really winning India over.
- Every episode.
- Thank you.
- It's Robin Norgren with
faithandcreativity.com
and Joseys Art School
thanking you for all that you
share with us entrepreneurs
or would-be entrepreneurs.
So my question is that
Hulu made a decision
recently to offer subscribers the option
to have ad-free subscriptions
and wanted to know what
your thoughts are on that.
We will keep asking questions.
I'm so glad that you keep answering them.
Thanks Gary Vee.
- You got it, thank you
for such a darling video.
Loved your earrings by the way.
I think it's a smart business model.
Some people value time,
hate ads enough to pay for a subscription.
Other people are willing
to go the other route.
They don't want to pay
for the subscription.
I think giving customers
two or three options.
My preference is three.
I think there's a lot of interesting
psycho-data around that,
to how they want to
experience a platform is very very smart.
I think it lends itself
to higher profit margins,
especially when you do three.
And so I think that's a
very smart move by Hulu.
I do not believe that one,
especially if you're a platform,
one option is the way to go.
As a matter of fact, if I
ever do a book by myself,
self-publish, because I'm a free agent
after this next book comes out.
That's right Harper Collins.
Call me back.
(laughter)
I would probably do
some really interesting
three different pricing models
where you get different options.
I think there's interesting
dynamics around that.
So I think Hulu made
a very smart decision.
As a matter of fact, I haven't
done a question of the day
but I'm going to throw
one in for a little while.
Just a little side question.
We'd love to see how
many people would rather
have one minute, well how
many ads are there in a Hulu,
probably like three, two
or three minutes right?
How many people are more into like,
you'll deal with the three minutes,
or how many people would rather pay
like the eight bucks or
whatever it is a month.
- [Staphon] 13 for like the actual--
- 13?
- [Staphon] Eight for like the ads.
- Got it.
So I'm curious.
- [India] YouTube just
announced theirs today.
- Yep, YouTube Red.
Saw that, haven't dug in yet.
But, yeah, I mean look.
I think subscription
models are very smart.
I think people are willing to pay for it
if they get the value of the content.
I think a lot of people
would pay for this show
if I ever decided to convert it.
Not a whole lot, but something.
As another side question,
if you were to pay,
and put zero dollars in the comments
on Facebook and YouTube.
If you were to pay, what would you pay
for a month subscription
of the #AskGaryVee Show?
It would be really good data.
And it would be really important for me,
and I'm not going to
do it, so don't worry.
I just want to know the truth.
So don't try to make me feel good,
and don't try to razz me.
Just tell me the truth.
Like hey, this is it.
The next 150, the rest of my life
I'm going to a subscription per month.
Here's a, you know, minimum of five, 20.
Minimum of what do you think?
Guaranteed 11 episodes per month?
12 if you like that we're at least
minimally bringing on that.
As many as 20.
What would you pay?
That would be interesting too.
I think it's good learnings for all of us.
So keep it real.
- [Voiceover] Dan asks
"Would 22 year old Gary Vee
"have watched the #AskGaryVee show?"
- Would 22 year old Gary Vee
#AskGaryVee Show?
Good question.
The answer is no.
Which is interesting, but true.
22 year old Gary knew he had it
and didn't want to
learn from other things.
Which I don't know if it's
a strength or a weakness,
but he believed in what he had in his body
and I believed in what I was going to be
and felt that my fresh naive eyes
and my intuition was more valuable
than putting things in my head
which would then be known as
well look at how that person
did it and they did it well.
I truly do believe that one of the reasons
that so many of you watch this show
is because I say things different,
I come from different angles,
and I really do believe that's because
I don't consume anybody else's stuff.
I think it helps me keep fresh.
I think my stuff comes from operating.
I think you know, just,
I'm giving you a wide view
because the background changed.
I think my stuff comes
from actually operating.
from an intuitive place.
And I don't, I don't
try to consume anything.
As a matter of fact I was at this event
where there was an opening
key note during the dinner
where I had to like meet with a client.
Boy I really didn't like it.
It was a really bad experience.
One I wanted to like go up,
I literally wanted to go up on stage
and hit him with a chair
WWF style and take over.
Like all right!
And you know like, I just don't
feel like that's my learning style.
So 22 year old Gary would
spit in the face of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
Sorry DRock.
And that's that.
Missed you guys a lot.
Really pumped to be back in the saddle.
We'll try to bring it
stronger and harder tomorrow.
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.